today the Matt wall show according to
the latest data nearly half of gen Z has
been diagnosed mentally ill how and why
is this mental illness epidemic
happening also a major Financial Scandal
involving one of the biggest Democrat
donors in the country plus is the woke
Brigade still in charge of Twitter and
church attendance has yet to climb back
to pre-pandemic levels will it ever is
the question and finally the Nea
teachers union claims that teachers know
and love their students more than their
parents do we'll talk about all that and
more today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Wade has been overturned and this battle
is now finally leaving DC and going to
the Grassroots no group in America is
better position than 40 Days for Life uh
to deal with that with about 1 million
Volunteers in a thousand cities 40 Days
for life holds peaceful vigils outside
abortion facilities they have a larger
presence in blue states with California
being their largest state some former
abortion facility directors say that
these vigils can cause the abortion
no-show rate to go as high as 75 percent
which is detrimental to detrimental to
their abortion business to say the least
these law-abiding vigils have closed
many abortion businesses in America and
nearly half of those closed abortion
facilities were in Liberal cities where
abortion will remain legal including
closures in San Francisco Chicago and
Seattle 40 Days for life is effectively
changing hearts and Minds in the
Grassroots to end abortion and you can
find out more if you check out their
locations podcasts and free magazine at
40daysforlife.com remember that
especially now after the midterms and
everything that's happened politically
it's more important than ever to stay
engaged in this fight and to do that you
got to get more information at 40 Days
for life.com again that's
40daysforlife.com
in the days after the election there has
been a lot of talk about the Democrat
party's dominance among young voters and
indeed they did in fact dominate
Republican house candidates won the 45
to 64 age bracket by 10 points they won
the 65 and over Group by even more than
that no surprise given that the
Democrats spent the entire you know
covid uh uh pandemic trying to murder
the elderly but that edge disappears in
the 30 to 44 demographic where Democrats
had a slight Edge it's almost 50 50
though and then there is Gen Z which
Democrats won by nearly 30 points
if the exit poll data is any indication
nearly twice as many in the 18 to 29
group voted Democrat as voted Republican
so that's gen Z and like the first part
of you know the the later parts of uh of
the millennial generation as well it's
no surprise to learn then that gen Z is
extremely mentally ill at least
according to the latest study uh which
uh we get this from the Christian post
it has the report nearly 70 percent of
Generation Z people born between 1997
and 2012 say their mental health was
adversely impacted by the kova 19
pandemic with 42 percent of adult
members of the cohort reporting that
they have been diagnosed with a mental
health condition and many of them say
they're worried about the future a new
study from the data management firm
Harmony Healthcare I.T shows the study
which is based on a survey of 1055 gen Z
members from the ages of 18 to 24 in
September included 47 men 45 percent
women six percent who identify as
non-binary and two percent trans
identified individuals according to the
report some 57 percent of gen Z adults
struggle with their mental health and
reported taking medication to alleviate
their condition and uh paid in an
average of 44 dollars monthly the most
frequently cited conditions where
anxiety and depression which were
reported by 90 percent and 78 percent of
respondents respectively other
conditions reported include ADHD 27 PTSD
20 OCD 17 Eating Disorders 14 and
insomnia 12 less than 10 percent
reported uh more diagnoses of bipolar
disorder uh addiction and substance
abuse and borderline personality
disorder while only one in five reported
going to therapy for their mental health
and spending an average of 149 dollars
monthly to do so 87 percent of them
found it helpful
okay so nearly half of an entire
Generation Now qualify as mentally ill
according to their diagnosis
when you break it down the numbers seem
to become even more troubling
20 of that group allegedly have been
diagnosed with PTSD
nearly 20 percent with OCD 14 with an
eating disorder I mean these are
staggering figures
and however we make sense of it all it's
clear that something is very wrong here
to put it mildly so how do we make sense
of it well to that end I'll make three
points there are a lot more than three
points worth making here but these are
the three things that I'd like to focus
on
right now
first
mental illness is a real thing there are
legitimate mental illnesses that people
suffer from
but the only way you end up with half of
a generation diagnosed mentally ill is
if the definition of mental illness has
been steadily expanded so as to include
everyone or as close to everyone as they
can get as I've worn for years these
so-called mental health industry has a
vested interest an obvious financial
interest to the tune of many billions of
dollars in finding labeling and
medicating as many mental illnesses as
they possibly can
we're at a point now where
you know every emotion you might
experience every fear every anxiety
every uncomfortable feeling or thought
has been turned into an illness or the
symptom of an illness
The Human Condition itself has been
medicalized and gen Z has grown up in a
culture where every inner experience
outside of the norm however the hell the
norm is defined
is considered a symptom of a mental
disease
they have been conditioned to seek the
Solace of a mental of a medical
diagnosis and so it is uh no surprise
that they have sought and found so many
of them
now
does that mean
just so I'm not misunderstood here
does that mean that the mental illness
epidemic in young people is fake
no it means that it's manufactured which
is certainly not the same thing as fake
I mean it's there's something real
happening here but it is manufactured
eventually the entire generation I mean
literally almost all of them if these
Trends continue
will be diagnosed mentally ill
and although many of these Newfound
mental patients never should have been
diagnosed to begin with they will
increasingly become as mentally sick as
the medical industry says they are it's
a self-fulfilling prophecy
why is that because they're not given
the tools to cope with normal emotional
and psychological experiences they are
made to rely on medication
they are made to feel helpless
like they simply cannot control their
own minds or their own emotions or how
they respond to those emotions
and the sicker they're made to feel the
sicker they'll become and act
I mean think of all the people in gen Z
saying they have PTSD
you know PTSD is something we normally
think of of uh you know people veteran
combat veterans coming home from war and
think about all the things that they've
experienced and seen and they're
suffering from PTSD now that makes sense
you've been in a in a truly traumatic
environment
but to have 20 of this group saying they
have PTSD
these are these aren't for the most part
combat veterans we're talking about
and yes they've been through some
difficult things the way that we handled
covid was was absolutely inexcusable of
course but
post-traumatic stress disorder
these are many of them people living
very comfortable lives
so what does the PTSD diagnosis comes
from comes comes from
it comes from kids and now young adults
who have not been given the tools to
cope with any difficult emotions at all
they just don't know how to deal with
anything
and so any challenge at all becomes
traumatic and now they're now suffering
from PTSD
again it's manufactured there is an
enormous generation white epidemic of
Munchausen by proxy happening right now
that's basically what's happened
speaking of which the second point is
that gender ideology is without question
one of the primary driving forces here
this is something that conservatives
often get wrong I think because they
confuse the chicken with the egg
it's not that so many in gen Z identify
as non-binary or trans or whatever
because they're mentally ill it's rather
that so many are mentally ill because
they have been given these identities
through peer pressure and the powers of
social Contagion
the Adolescent girl who first begins to
fall into the trans trap she's not sick
there's no mental illness driving that
at least there doesn't have to be but
once she falls into the Trap completely
that is when the mental sickness begins
to form and take hold so for a good
example of this phenomenon here's the
latest Tick Tock Innovation one of the
latest identities fresh uh you know it's
a one of one of the one of the freshest
ones uh right out of the oven it's
called trigender watch this
so a couple of people might have been
surprised by my transgender pin that I
put on this morning
I figured it's about time that I came
out and talked about my gender identity
I am trigender which means like a
triangle I have three genders male
female and non-binary
and the difference between trigender and
gender fluid is that I feel all three of
these genders at the same time
all the time it doesn't ever shift or
change or where I feel one gender more
strongly than the other like gender
fluid tends to be
also I should recognize and accept that
a lot of people don't see non-binary as
a third gender they see it as something
completely separate from the binary of
male and female
um but for me
it's like a third gender
or I guess you could call it a Third
identity
so how I feel gender wise is like a man
like a woman and as neither at the same
time
I hope this clears things up but let me
know if you have any more questions I'm
happy to answer
I do have questions actually quite a lot
she says she's male female both and
neither at the same time now that
obviously makes no sense at all it's the
definition of a logical foul so you
cannot be something and the opposite of
that thing at the same time it's like
identifying as a married Bachelor it is
a self-contradiction
so is the girl in the video Simply crazy
is she suffering from mental delusions
it's possible and appearances would
suggest that such is the case
but it need not be the case
what's more likely is that she's simply
trying to fit in with the fed and find
her own trendy Twist on it but the more
that she tries to live in this
nonsensical identity the more confused
she will actually become the more
detached from reality and the more
plagued by anxiety at the same time I
mean keep in mind as I am always saying
that that
um you know the really Sinister thing
about gender ideology and is that when
someone becomes fully enthralled to it
they will have lost grip not just on
reality in general but on the reality of
themselves
and there's a lot that comes from this
and one of those things is anxiety
because anxiety is the unease that comes
from uncertainty it comes from the
unknown it's why you know you don't like
uh walking down into a dark basement at
night because you don't know what's down
there and uh your mind sort of fills in
the gaps with all the terrifying
possibilities it's why Joe Biden's
handlers become very nervous whenever he
steps in front of a microphone because
they have no idea what he's going to say
or whatever you know childhood story
he's going to make up this is all
anxiety so gender ideology is like an
anxiety machine because it makes a
person's fundamental physical identity
uncertain to themselves creating a sort
of unrelenting anxiety
it's no surprise then that gen Z are
reporting record levels of anxiety
at precisely the time when these kinds
of ideas are gaining prominence
ideas which in effect turn out the
intellectual lights
turning our minds into that dark scary
basement
which brings me to my third point
um I said at the beginning that it's no
surprise that gen Z voted Democrat
because so many are diagnosed mentally
ill and uh I wasn't being facetious
there at least I wasn't being entirely
facetious facetious there is a
relationship it does actually make a lot
of sense
because we know with Gen z uh not only
does this make them susceptible to to
Identity politics and all that that the
Democrats can exploit
but also because they have all of this
anxiety in their heads uh in their minds
and they don't know what to do with it
and they don't know how to cope with it
again having anxiety is a normal thing
it's part of the human condition
nobody likes it but it's part of the
human gets one of the things that makes
us human is that we can experience
anxiety
by the Democrat Party thrives on
exploiting anxiety
that's how they motivate people to vote
if you listen to things that gen Z you
know their exit poll data what were they
concerned about why did they go to the
poll to vote it's things like climate
change
you know they're actually worried about
that
they think the world's coming to an end
they think that America systemically
races that there are white supremacists
murderers walking around out there you
know
this is this is their view of the world
they're full of anxiety the Democrat
Party is able to exploit it and convert
that into votes
which is why as I've been saying all
along
we have a long road ahead in this fight
for the culture
and the fight is in in every sense of
the term generational
now let's get to our five headlines
you know if you're listening to the show
and you're a parent odds are that you
put a lot of stock in how you raise your
kids you understand that your children
look to you to Define their values and
their perspectives of the world that's
why it's extremely important that you
have a will in place a will determines
how your financial assets are dispersed
as well as your personal property it
lays uh lays out your Healthcare power
of attorney to ensure that your end of
life decisions are carried out if you're
just starting out and you don't have
thousands of dollars to spend on an
attorney but you want to make sure your
savings your belongings and your family
are all protected you have to create a
will at epicwill.com today you don't
need a lot of money in fact early estate
plans started just 119 and you can save
10 percent when you use promo code Walsh
all you got to do is go to epicwill.com
use promo code Walsh to save 10 on Epic
Will's complete will package that's
epicwill.com promo code Welsh
we start with this story from the daily
wire it says Sam bankman fried who's the
uh the now bankrupt founder of the
cryptocurrency exchange FTX
gave a staggering sum of money to
Democrats and far left causes this
Maritime election cycle before his
multi-billion Dollar Empire imploded
this week
which is something by the way that
happens so you've got this Mega Democrat
donor
um donated more than anybody else next
to George Soros
the Democrat causes and all of this
explodes right after the midterms
well we're still in the middle of the
midterms actually because they haven't
even counted all the votes yet but uh
but right after voting allegedly
concluded uh that's what all this comes
up
daily wire has more information about
this FTX which is headquartered in the
Bahamas was launched in 2019 and had
accrued more than one million users by
2022. users suddenly demanded six
billion dollars in withdrawals after an
article published by coindesk revealed
last week that the two arms of benkman
fried's cryptocurrency Empire FTX and
Alameda research had significant overlap
on their balance sheets in the form of
the cryptocurrency ftt which FTX
invented rival firm binance which had
been planning to purchase FDX announced
that it would discharge all Holdings in
the coin and eventually reverse course
on the acquisition the disheveled 30
year old went from boasting a 15.6
billion dollar net worth to having no
material wealth over the span of
approximately two days federal and state
officials are now investigating whether
banking fried broke laws with his
actions at the company you would think
that he certainly did
now uh so SBF there are a lot of
initials going on here but you've got
SBF who's the guy that owns FTX and uh
that is the uh the that's the the
organization the company that invented
ftt which is the cryptocurrency so all
these things are confusing but SPF
um
was the second largest donor for
Democrats this election cycle only
behind as I said George Soros he gave at
least 38 million dollars to leftist
causes Pacs and candidates according to
Fox News political reported that bankman
fried was a top resource to whom
Democrats when when lawmakers began
looking at ways to regulate
cryptocurrencies because of his
willingness to write multi-million
dollar checks to boost Democrats
and the deeper you dive into this
relationship between
um SBF
and the Democrat Party the more you find
for example the post-millennial has this
report
uh it says the multi-billion dollar
cryptocurrency company FTX run by SBF
the second biggest owner after George
Soros collapsed last week so we know
about that it was revealed that FDX had
partnered with Ukraine to process
donations to their War efforts within
days of Joe Biden pledging billions of
American taxpayer dollars to the country
Ukraine invested into FTX
as the bite Administration funneled
funds to the invaded nation and FTX then
made massive donations to Democrats in
the U.S
a lot of this comes from an article from
the cryptocurrency news website coindesk
from March 15 2022 reported that Ukraine
partnered with FDX and that FDX is
converting crypto contributions to
Ukraine's war effort into Fiat for
deposit the National Bank of Ukraine
okay
so
if you follow the uh the trajectory
there and you connect all the dots you
don't have to connect a lot of them
but Ukraine invested into
FDX
FTX is investing into Democrats
and who's investing into Ukraine
the fact you were and you still are
whether you like it or not and I
certainly don't
so the Democrat Party this is
interesting Democrat parties funneling
money to Ukraine
which then partners with FTX
and the FTX turns around and gives a lot
of money to Democrats
you might even call that a money
laundering scheme
in fact that's exactly what you should
call it
it's like a giant money laundering
scheme
and not the only one the Democrats have
by the way
they've got a lot of these things going
on
where they funnel money to organizations
and the organizations give the money
right back to them
um you know not not to not to distract
from from the FDX Scandal which is
massive but we should also note that
this is this has been happening with
Planned Parenthood for decades
the Democrat Party gives 500 million
dollars a year to to uh to Planned
Parenthood and then Planned Parenthood
turns around and donates to Democrat
causes
and they always have ways of justifying
this or getting around it legally well
it's easy to write it legally when
nobody you know the FBI is not
interested in looking into it to begin
with but the way they do with with
Planned Parenthood is they say that uh
well but these are these are it's the
money's not going these are all separate
areas that the money is going to
yeah money's not going to fund abortions
except they're forgetting that the money
is fungible
and so if you give money to one aspect
of an organization then you have freed
up money in other places where they can
they can then spend how they want so
that excuse doesn't really wash
Democrat Party specializes in this kind
of thing is my point and that appears to
be what's happening with uh FTX now
you know I just started reading about
this last night and I'm far from an
expert on anything crypto related
or on this issue
but
it is quite obvious already that the
deeper you dig into this the bigger the
Scandal becomes
and already Sam bankman fried is you
know he's in the Bernie Madoff
conversation
at the just the the the the the uh
the scope of this scam this Ponzi scheme
that he was running
but
we're never going to find out the full
scope of it unless the media is
interested in looking into it
and if the federal government is
interested in investigating it
which they certainly are not going to be
because he was a major Democrat donor
and it should be obvious by now this is
the reason why he was a major Democrat
Don
it's actually pretty smart
um and it does take intelligence even to
run a scam as big as what he was running
even if it all it all did fall apart
it's pretty clear that he was donating
Democrats because he knows they're the
ones who run the media they're the ones
who run the government even no matter
who's in the white White House Democrats
are still running it and um
when all this blows up they're not going
to be interested in coming after him
because they don't want all of these
ties to come to light and what are they
going to do give the money back I mean
they should they're not going to
the other part of this too is just
cryptocurrency itself and you know I I
said before that I uh
I don't understand
cryptocurrency I'm not an expert in it
and I've always said that
but I I've I'm increasingly coming to to
realize that uh those of us who say well
I don't really understand the whole
crypto thing
it's we actually do understand it
but it's like our first reaction to it
we first heard about is that it sounds
totally arbitrary and fake and made up
and uh and and absurd
and so we always assume those of us who
say we can't understand we assume that
well there must be something more to it
that I'm just not getting I must not be
getting it because what what you're
explaining to me about cryptocurrency it
just it sounds like a just like a a
fantasy just a a bubble floating in the
air that can easily pop
and people are putting their money into
this like actual real money
well you can you can invent a digital
coin and then just declare that it's
worth something
and it's only worth something if
everyone else plays along that's that's
what's keeping all this afloat is that
everyone's playing along with it
what happens when they stop playing
along
well the value plummets
so for a lot of us that was our first
reaction to cryptocurrency we first
heard about it years ago that's why we
didn't get invested maybe we assumed
that there must be something that we're
just not getting but no there isn't
there isn't more to it that really is it
it's just uh it's just it's nothing it's
like something that floats out in The
Ether
and as long as everyone plays along and
agrees to pretend that these these
numbers on a screen mean something then
it will have value and then the moment
that we all say you know what I'm not
into that anymore it just plummets to
the Earth
and I know that the response that is
always well that's the same thing with
fiat currency it's the same thing with
our money right now what's you know
what's happening with inflation
you know that only has value because we
essentially believe in it
which you're right but then what that
tells us is that cryptocurrency it's not
solving any of the problems caused by
fiat currency it has all the same
problems but only worse it magnifies all
of those problems doesn't solve them
it's like you're doubling down on what
makes fiat currency unreliable and
unstable
by coming up with something that's even
less reliable and even more unstable
seems to me we should be going in the
other direction all right
moving to this also from daily watches
Republicans will fail to gain enough
seats to take back the Senate majority
according to a projection by decision
desk headquarter headquarters the the
Senate will remain under Democratic
control since ties are broken by the
Vice President
the protection came after decision desk
headquarters called the Nevada race for
the Democrats the partisan makeup of the
Senate will be decided after December 6
sent out Senate runoff between Herschel
Walker and Rafael Warnock
which even if Walker
wins that one it's the Republicans at
this point will not be able to take
control of the Senate because Camille
Harris will still have the tie-breaking
vote although it's certainly much better
to win it than not obviously because
then you've got the 50 50 we're back to
what it was before and depending on what
the bill is what the legislation is
maybe you can peel Joe manchin or
somebody off
um but if Walker loses that race then
then you know that's Joe manchin's dream
come true now he's off the hook it
doesn't matter what he does
so
it looked like it was trending this
direction last week and this is where we
are now
um
and when I say trending in that
direction you know it's
uh the Democrats kept on Counting the
votes and kept on Counting them until
they had won the Senate
that's what I mean by trending in that
direction
um
this from Breitbart Senator Josh Hawley
is calling for Republican party to
undergo reform after it was projected
the party would not gain control of the
U.S Senate Saturday night he said the
old party is dead time to bury it build
something new
um and he said that reaction to a
republican Adam laxalt losing in the
Nevada Senate race and this is after the
the Democrat the Republicans lost the
Senate this is what most people are
saying now
um and as far as the house goes I mean
they're still counting the votes as it
stands right now somehow they are still
counting votes we're almost a week out
and they're still counting them because
this is what this is how a modern
election is supposed to work or it takes
you a week week to count the vote they
still have not been able to explain why
exactly it takes that long
I've I've listened to all the press
conferences
where the people in charge have
answered questions and supposedly
explained why it takes us long and I
still don't understand why it takes this
long
I mean I think I do understand it but
it's not it's not an answer they're
going to give out loud
there's no good reason why it should
take a week to count the votes
and what they especially have not been
able to explain is why can't they go
talk to Florida
how do they manage to count
you know many more votes in a small
fraction of the time
they've got many more millions of votes
to counts they do it they do it in five
hours
and it takes you over five days
in Arizona Nevada et cetera
but this is what Republicans are saying
that uh we got to burn the party to the
Ground start over I agree with that
I absolutely agree obviously we need new
leadership
as I said
the day after the election
you know there are we can we can spend
uh weeks and months doing the
post-mortem and and uh and and debating
why the Republicans lost and there are a
lot of things that went into it
one of them of course is how these
elections are run to begin with and the
fact that it does take a week to quote
unquote count them
that's part of it it's not just that
it's also as I said the Republican party
on a national level had no message I
mean what was the Republicans party
party's message I don't know
man I know their message was
Joe Biden is bad that that's a fine
message we all agree with that
the voters seem to agree with it
which is why all the exit poll data
shows that voters were upset with the
direction of the country they were
fearful and anxiety ridden about the
direction of the country and yet
many of them still voted for the party
that has that is currently taking them
in the direction that they say they
don't want to go
what does that mean it means that uh
your message cannot just be a negative
of this guy's bad which you have to be
able to explain is why we have a better
vision for the country and here's what
the vision is and they weren't able to
do that
so that's that's one of the lessons that
we should take from this
well the other question then is what do
we do about this system
you know Democrats are able to dominate
in these states
because ballot harvesting mail-in voting
early voting
and I think
almost any conservative that will say
that at this point
that none of that should be happening
okay as I've said a million times the
voting should be on Election Day with
rare exception
active duty military being one of them
maybe there are a couple others you can
name but with rare exception voting is
on Election Day the polls are open from
this hour to this hour you show up there
in person Flesh and Blood you walk in
there you cast your vote and you you
produce your ID and then you leave
that's the way that it should work
but
it's it's not working that way and the
problem is
that Pennsylvania
Nevada Arizona
how are we going to convince the
Democrats that run these states to
change the voting procedures
to disadvantage themselves
it's just never going to happen they're
not going to do it
you know we can't say to them well this
gives you an unfair Advantage stop doing
it
that can be that could be our claiming
that's basically what we've been saying
as we're kind of impotently whining
about it
but that's not going to be a compelling
argument to them because the whole point
is that it gives them an unfair
Advantage they're aware of that that's
why they're doing it
and so how do you when you don't have
power how do you convince them to change
something
to take an advantage away from
themselves it's never going to happen
so what can you do if you really want to
change the system you want to change the
way that that uh that elections are run
in these states you have to take control
you have to have power in order to do it
and unfortunately in order to do it in
order to take control of the system you
have to
you have to do that through the system
itself you have to be able to use the
system that you want to change if you
want to change a system you first have
to understand how to use it to your
advantage and exploit it
so that you can take control of it and
once you've done that then you can
change it
so
what we have to decide is is uh as
conservatives we can keep
stomping our feet and whining about the
early voting and mail and voting and all
the rest of it
and I and I and emotionally I fully
understand that approach
because I hate it also
and we can keep doing that and nothing's
going to change
because the Democrats in Pennsylvania
and Arizona Nevada and the other states
they're gonna they're gonna they listen
to us and they laugh
and that's all they're going to do
so the other approach is to learn how to
is to start exploiting
the systems that are in place
I don't think they should have mail-in
voting I don't think they should have
early voting
but they do
and so
if we ever want to change that or
anything else then we have to learn how
to exploit that how to use that to our
advantage
right in so many cases now it seems like
Republicans have kind of crossed their
arms and said I don't agree with this so
I'm just not going to take part well
we're only hurting ourselves when we do
that
and so the Democrats are basically
running unopposed
it created these tools for themselves
and and they're and they've they have a
monopoly on it because we haven't even
tried to take advantage of it ourselves
and uh and nothing's ever going to
change
you have to be able to use the system
and learn how to navigate it if you want
to take control of it and change it
that's just the reality
all right
what else do we got here so
uh I thought this was funny
uh some some journalists on on Twitter
are complaining you know because Elon
Musk taking over Twitter and uh and he's
already fired a bunch of people and
they're complaining about that well
here's the latest from a New York Times
article and a guy named Bill grueskin
tweets this he says Mr Mr musk plans to
begin making employees pay for lunch
which had been free at the company
cafeteria and a guy named Andrew Wartman
responds to that he said he fired
three-fourths of the employees now he's
planning to starve the rest of them
he's failure incarnate
yes now the Twitter employees are and
musk actually responded to this and said
that look most the employees don't even
come to the office so I don't think I'm
going to starve them to begin with but
also
you know they're working at at
Twitter it's uh so they they have jobs
they probably should be able to pay for
their own lunches
now it's nice to get a free lunch every
day don't get me wrong we actually we
get that here at the daily wire they
provide us catered lunch every day it's
what's it's it's fantastic if you can
get it
but if they were to take that perk away
from us I don't think I would just sit
here and starve I would probably just
you know you could pack a lunch or go go
buy lunch somewhere
so these are these really Petty
complaints that we're still hearing
about
the Elon Musk takeover of a Twitter but
there are complaints that you can make
that are not as Petty
so for example over the weekend
um our great reporter Christina buttons
here at the daily wire she tweeted out a
link to a report that she just did for
the daily wire
and um the headline of that report is
new data emerges of 1 100 plus
adolescent gender affirming mastectomies
and then she tweets it with this caption
she says new data a study of Nationwide
Hospital databases found that at least
1130 adolescents between 2016 and 2019
received gender affirming chest
surgeries gender affirming in quotes
chest surgeries in the U.S an
overwhelming majority
114 of The Adolescents were female
um and so that's it that's the report
now
this isn't even an editorial this is
just Christina buttons
uh
presenting the information the data
which says that over this span you know
well over a thousand minor girls had
their their breasts amputated
in in pursuit of this uh of this aim of
becoming a boy which of course they can
never become
well
if you tried to click on that link on
Twitter over the weekend this is what
would have happened this is what
happened to me when I tried it myself
a warning page comes up and it says
warning this link may be unsafe
it says the link you're trying to access
has been identified by Twitter or our
partners as being potentially spammy or
unsafe in accordance with Twitter's URL
polls this link could fall into any of
the below categories
and then it says it could be a Spam it
could be a malicious link that's
stealing information or of course it's
none of those things or it could be
violent or misleading content that could
lead to real world harm
so if the content is violent or
misleading then this warning page comes
up now it does give you an option
there's a there's a you know a button
there at the top that says you can click
and go back to the previous page get
away from the unsafe content or in
smaller letters below that it says
ignore this warning and continue and
then you can get to the article
so factual information
[Music]
about the mutilation that's being
inflect inflicted on children in this
country
by these so-called gender affirming
doctors
that factual information is flagged on
Twitter
as unsafe and it could lead to harm
somehow
this is actually worse than it was
before Elon Musk took over
you know I don't remember ever seeing a
warning page like that pop up for an
article like this before
so it's not just that um
you know we still have the same wokeness
now that Elon Musk it's actually it's
actually worse in this way
and that's uh extremely concerning now
you know I've tweeted this out over the
weekend uh there there were people
pointing out saying that hey we need to
be a little bit more patient and a
little more generous with Elon Musk here
and he did he just took over the company
can't fix everything right away and I
and I understand that
you know Rome wasn't built in a day and
all that
and you certainly can't fix it in a day
but all the same I mean as as I said
last week you know he a musk had did
right away Institute some major changes
the changes that he made with the
verification process and then they ended
up abandoning that after like two days
because it was a total disaster but they
did Implement major structural changes
right away
so it seems as though they could have
cleaned a lot of this up right away and
they haven't yet
that doesn't mean they won't in the
future
but it does mean that the the woke
Brigade is still there at Twitter and
they're still running things to a large
extent
and if you really want to change that I
mean Elon Musk is already half fired
like whatever it is half of the company
you got to fire but the basically fire
almost everyone and build the company
over again from scratch
to actually fix this problem
all right this is from the daily wire
also says churches in the United States
are struggling to return to attendance
levels seen prior to coveted lockdowns
before that shut their doors and forced
online services according to a new
LifeWay research poll the survey
released last week was conducted with a
thousand Protestant pastors from
September 6th to the 30th from a random
sample of Protestant churches the survey
revealed that despite churches failing
to return to pre-lockdown levels the
majority had resumed in-person worship
services
now this doesn't surprise me at all as
someone I don't go to Protestant
churches I'm Catholic obviously but I
have noticed this myself I think anyone
who goes to church every Sunday we we
all notice this
that um and I've been to a bunch of
different churches
you know in in several different states
over the last couple of years and I've
noticed this everywhere that attendance
appears to be significantly lower than
it would have been before the pandemic
um
is that problem going to write itself I
mean here's the question are the
churches ever going to get back to
pre-pandemic levels of attendance
and I'm skeptical that that will happen
I'm skeptical for a few reasons one is
that the culture keeps moving away from
us
um as you know successive Generations
are more Godless more likely to be
atheists secularism takes holoculture
more and more so you're already okay so
you're already trying to swim upstream
because of that
but then at the same time
and this was my objection at the very
beginning this was my objection to
Church's closing to begin with
is that when you do that and you shut
your doors you are
um
you are telling your congregants you're
telling your flocks
that you are not necessary
that you the church as the church what
you're saying to to the congregation is
that what we're doing here is not
necessary
remember this was um
this was during the time that only
essential only essential workers were
allowed to go away all the essential
Services uh are allowed to stay open but
all the non-essential Services have to
be shut down
and state governments they declared that
well churches are non-essential service
and unfortunately a lot of churches and
there were some exceptions to this but a
lot of churches went along with that and
agreed with it whether explicitly or
implicitly
and said you're right we're not we're
not essential
once you've told your congregation that
once you've advertised that
once you once you have sent that message
uh you're not going to be able to get
them all back
because I think there are a lot of
people who were going to church before
that then the church is shut down said
well we're not an essential service so
we could stay shut down for as long as
as the government tells us to
until everyone stops having the sniffles
we can just shut the doors
there are many churches that stayed shut
for months on end if not longer than
that
and then many members of the
congregation said well
apparently you're not essential
apparently we don't need you
and you open your doors again but it's
uh what's the point of going back
I don't agree with that church is
essential
you know as we're told in scripture it's
uh man does not live on bread alone
you also you also have to feed yourself
spiritually that is that is an essential
service
but unfortunately the the church is
broadcast the opposite message
and that has uh sunk in and I don't know
if there's ever going to be any undoing
that completely let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
you know with everything going on in the
world right now you could really use a
good night's sleep I know I could that's
why you need to check out Helix mattress
I've had my Helix for years now and I
absolutely love it I sleep like a baby
even in the midst of it's arguably my
busiest season and I've got twins on the
way so I don't know if I'll be doing
much sleeping then but at least I'll be
comfortable for the little fits of time
when I can sleep a mattress should never
be a one size fits-all solution because
why should you have to compromise on
Comfort he looks as a sleep quiz that
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you because why would you buy a mattress
made for somebody else so go to
helixsleep.com Walsh take their
two-minute sleep quiz and find the
perfect mattress for your body and your
sleep type your mattress will come right
to your door for free plus Helix has a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk free it'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but trust me you will there are
financing options and flexible payment
plans make it so that a great night's
sleep is never far away so for a limited
time Helix is offering up to 350 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners this is an amazing offer
you can take advantage of it at
helixsleep.com Walsh with Helix better
sleep starts now
the mall says when it comes to voting we
should not have names on the ballots but
rather people have to write them down
themselves that way a voter at least
knows how to spell and as and knows at
least a little bit about the candidate
obviously this isn't even close to
perfect but I think it's a start that's
not a bad strategy I love that idea I
think it's actually a really good idea
um now maybe you wouldn't require that
of all the of the candidates on the
ballot but uh certainly the candidates
at the top of the ticket
and certainly in a presidential election
if it were up to me yeah I like that
idea and I would adopt that right away
you actually have to write the name of
the candidate that you want on the
ballot
because if you don't if you if you if
you can't even do that
like if you need the name to be there
ahead of time
because you don't know the names
um then
you know you are voting purely out of
ignorance
and your work you are working to
undermine the Democratic process and and
harm the country in the process
so I would agree with you on that I
think that's a great idea and you have
to spell it correctly too
so if you misspell it
then the ballot goes out the window goes
in the trash
but here's my point this is this is a
this is a fun kind of like fan fiction
thing to indulge in
if we were serious if we were actually
serious about uh
about
protecting and preserving our Republic
these are the kinds of things we would
do
but it's just never going to happen
right like that of course what you're
suggesting you're not suggesting it as a
as a as a as a strategy that will ever
actually be adopted it's just in an
Ideal World if you if you really wanted
to protect your democracy then these are
the sorts of things you might think
about doing
and so it's okay to talk about that I
talk about it all the time we should
talk about those things we should talk
about what we would do in an ideal
scenario
because you have to know what the ideal
is so that you know which direction you
should be traveling in
but then the next step is to realize
that we're not in an ideal scenario
we're living in reality and so how are
we going to navigate we got the ideal
right so we know the direction we want
to go but now we have the reality and so
how do we navigate the reality
in a way that brings us at least a
little bit closer to that ideal
uh David said
it just occurred to me that Matt Walsh
will be wanting to take some time off
when his twins are born perhaps the
daily wire could contact the people at
Hallmark and bring in his doppelganger
to host for a couple of weeks just an
idea I would love that I would do that
for sure
um and uh yeah I certainly will be
taking some time off but uh I'm not
going to pull up Pete Budaj so you have
to worry about that taking six months
off from eternity to leave
um
Adam says Matt you were talking about
dealing with haters and hateful
threatening people at your rallies Etc
what advice would you give on how to
deal with people who see it as their
mission to hate and ridicule I have
dealt with some of this lately and as
much as I wish it hadn't it really has
rattled my cage thanks SBG for life well
the only way to deal with people like
that is to realize that their opinion
doesn't mean anything
and I know it's a little bit easier said
than done so I can tell you that and it
doesn't mean that you're going to be
able to like emotionally adopt that
right away but but that is that is that
is
the only way to deal with such people
is to realize that their opinion simply
doesn't matter
and especially if you're doing the right
thing
and you're living according to your
beliefs
and you're speaking the truth and you're
defending the truth
all the all of the
sniping idiots
and all the little trolls and vultures
who come after you none of their
opinions matter at all
and you so you have to get to a point of
uh
of indifference basically to them
I'm not going to say you have to hate
them or be angry at them they just
indifferent
and I don't recommend indifference in
many different in in in very many
situations but this is one situation
where indifference is the way you have
to be indifferent to what they think
Jamie Jones says I was an iron worker
for many years in our Apprenticeship
Training we're required to learn eight
or ten different knots including the new
slip knot
um new slash Slipknot they're easy to
make great for moving things floor to
Florida skeleton building and they don't
bind up they slip apart hence the name
the stupidity flowing from the left
causes me physical pain yeah there's a
lot of comments for people in the
construction world who were uh you know
agreeing that in fact uh ropes are very
common on construction sites even things
that might look like a a a a noose or a
slip knot
might actually be one but there are
practical applications for that
so that could explain as we talked about
the daily cancellation on Friday you
know that could explain this epidemic of
uh construction sites across the country
shutting down for days at a time because
somebody finds a scary rope and decides
that it's a racist symbol
what's the other thing about that is I I
have to again remind you that
um
not only are these news stories almost
always either hoaxes
or some very stupid person is
misinterpreting an innocuous rope that's
that was being used for some other
reason
that's all true
but also the whole idea that a noose is
a racist symbol to begin with is
invented that's invented by the media
it's like they invented the okay sign as
a uh as a as a racist symbol that's a
media invention
I mean yes nooses
in the past
have been used in racist lynchings that
that's obviously true
but also the Noose has been used as a as
a method of execution for thousands of
years all over the country
all over the world rather I should say
for thousands of years
so the idea that it specifically has
this one meaning now just uh doesn't
make any sense to begin with
you know last year we launched Our Daily
News podcast morning wire in this short
period of time it's become one of the
top news podcasts I suspect it's because
morning wire gives you only the news you
need to know in 15 minutes or less
without the manufactured outrage new
episodes are available every morning
seven days a week and they cover stories
other media Outlets won't touch so check
out morning wire on daily wire plus
Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you
listen to podcasts now let's get to our
daily cancellation
foreign
last week we briefly discussed the
latest bout of verbal flatulence from
representative Eric swalwell who
critiqued the idea that parents should
be in charge of their own children's
education as you recall swalwell said
please tell me what I'm missing here
what are we doing next putting patients
in charge of their own surgeries clients
in charge of their own trials when did
we all when did we stop trusting experts
this is so stupid and indeed this is so
stupid everything you said is so stupid
as we covered clients are in charge of
the representation at trial and patients
are in charge of their surgeries now
they may delicate delegate many of those
responsibilities which is a highly
recommended approach especially when it
comes to surgery but they are still
supposed to be the ones in charge
basically the ones deciding
um as for the self-appointed experts
well many of us stopped trusting them
when they shut down Society over covid
uh waged war against our fundamental
civil rights only to spend the next two
years slowly admitting that all of their
pandemic strategies were based on lies
some of us may have also stopped
trusting them when they started pushing
for gender confused children to get
mutilated castrated and sterilized and
then there are those of us who never
stopped trusting the experts because we
never started trusting them to begin
with
these points are all academic because
Public School teachers
are not experts anyway they are by no
means experts in the subjects they teach
nor are they experts in teaching
necessarily some of them may certainly
have reached the point of expertise
through years of experience but as a
class as a as a group
they cannot be called experts especially
because most teachers start teaching
before the age of 25. some of them are
as young as 20 or 21. lots of them are
when they start you can't be an expert
in anything at that age you certainly
aren't going to be an expert in teaching
kids who are barely younger than
yourself
so swallow well is wrong on every level
and from every conceivable angle as per
usual but the interesting point
is that he came out explicitly against
parental rights just a day or two after
the election
the left has gotten even Bolder than
usual over the past several days having
decided that the results of the midterms
vindicate and validate all of their most
extreme talking points
this conclusion is of course erroneous
especially when it comes to parental
rights of all issues in fact Republicans
up the ballot may have fared relatively
poorly in most States but as we talked
about last week conservatives and School
Board races were much more successful
the daily wire reports quote this week
conservatives flipped at least nine
school boards in at least six states
Michigan Maryland North Carolina South
Carolina New Jersey and Florida giving
them conservative majorities according
to two parental rights groups who
endorsed many of the Victorious
candidates the wind signal that parental
rights were a significant factor at The
Ballot Box on Tuesday in Michigan four
School Board candidates in Brandywine
who were endorsed by a parents right
group Rights group called 1776 project
PA Pack won their races flipping the
board from Liberal to conservative in
Maryland three of their school board
candidates one in Carroll County
flipping the school board there to a
conservative majority the 76 1776
project pack claims that it has um
officially flipped 100 school boards
since November last year the group's
candidates also won in Oklahoma and Ohio
another parents Rights group moms for
Liberty told the daily wire that it
notched clusters of winds in at least
four states the group flipped at least
seven School boards in North Carolina
conservative candidates won in both New
Hanover County and Iredale County
flipping both of those School Board
boards conservatives in South Carolina
six conservative candidates one in
Berkeley County 5-1 in Charleston County
and another 4-1 in York County flipping
all three School Board to the
conservative side moms for Liberty also
said that in New Jersey three candidates
in Cape May County won their elections
flipping that school board conservative
in Florida two candidates one in
Pinellas County flipping that board
conservative as well so in other words
the left decides at its own Peril that
parents groups and parents rights are a
losing political issue
the results indicate actually the
exactly the opposite of that
Republicans only lost on the issue of
parental rights if they chose not to run
on it in the first place and many of
them made that choice
you can't win the argument if you don't
make the argument
and the argument for parental rights is
very easy to make and it will
automatically resonate with the vast
majority of parents that's the thing
about us parents whether we identify
with the political left or right we
don't like it when someone tries to
parent our children for us
somebody should tell that to the
National Education Association teachers
union which also decided after the
election that they now have political
permission to explicitly attack parental
rights so on Friday the Nea tweeted this
quote Educators love their students and
know better than anyone what they need
to learn and to thrive
better than anyone they say
now the phrasing there is quite
deliberate obviously
the teachers union is claiming that
teachers know better than parents what
their children need
but that is of course exactly wrong it
is the opposite of reality in fact the
very best argument for homeschooling is
that parents not Public School teachers
are experts in the most important field
now most parents just as most teachers
don't have phds in math or science or
any other academic discipline but they
are experts on one thing which is their
children they're experts on their
children
parents know or should know their own
children better than anyone
so the Nea accidentally raises a good
point here
the most effective educator is going to
be the person who knows the child best
to understands him who knows what he
needs and can tailor the education to
fit those needs and that last step is
very important because even if a public
school teacher does come to understand a
child's educational needs which is a big
if considering that the teacher will
likely have 20 or 30 other students in
the class only about 45 minutes in a day
to teach them any given subject
so it's very difficult to get to know
any of the kids but but even if the
teacher does
um he's not going to have he will have
only a very limited ability to respond
to the child's needs even if the teacher
comes to understand what those needs are
a teacher can't give
30 different kids their own personalized
and customized educational environment
it's impossible
and that's not because of the teacher's
personal limitations but rather it's
because of the way the system is set up
a worker on an assembly line probably
doesn't have
probably doesn't have the ability to
make the product by hand but even if he
does he can't do that while working on
the assembly line
the public school system is an assembly
line
the teachers are simply Manning their
stations along the conveyor belt and
even if they man them well and many of
them do there's only so much attention
they can give to each child as he is
ferried on Down the Line
so
yes it is important in education to know
the child well and to be able to respond
to know his needs and to be able to
respond to those needs
and that's why the parent is going to be
in a much better position and then What
About Love
well Public School teachers may love
their students in a broad and sort of
charitable sense right
but
they will not and cannot love the
student the way that a student's parents
can and should and most of the time do
love him
my wife and I we've been with our
children since they were born we feed
them and put clothes on their backs we
uh care for them when they're sick we're
the ones checking under their beds for
Monsters before we tuck them in at night
you know we know them and love them more
than anyone ever could
and that does make us better equipped to
educate them
because education is not simply about
passing along information after all it's
not merely a matter of memorizing
details and being able to repeat them
that's that's supposed to be just a part
of Education
but education as a whole properly
understood is supposed to be about
making someone a better person
now our educational system right now may
often have the opposite effect these
days especially at the college level but
a proper education
does mean or should mean instilling
virtue
and that requires care that requires
patience
um that requires love
which is why the parent should not only
be involved
but should in fact be in charge
and that is why today the Nea teachers
union is canceled and that'll do it for
this portion of the show as we move over
to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]